I am man I'm nervous actually
today's guest is my favorite comedian
living my favorite living comedian and
so I'm excited that he's here he has a
new special Netflix called
paper tiger and and he has a podcast
called the Monday morning podcast and it
also comes out sometimes on Thursdays
he's one of a kind ladies and gentlemen
mr. bill Bern
[Music]
yeah you'll see you just get to [ __ ] you
gotta like once you once you yeah you
know it's like no no no no no no no no
no and then all of a sudden nose become
yes out here and then then you just feel
like you know the first time you get yes
is you go okay to everything and then
then all of a sudden you just don't have
any [ __ ] time and then you've got to
like dial it back and then try to find
like quality but yeah that's I just had
to I just took some did some dates off
of the books I was I got a bunch of
stress man I was starting to lose my
mind I thought oh yeah no that's it
affects everybody differently so I just
yeah I just there's a good thing to is
just lying just say you're not available
that week I'm not in town
oh I already had him so yeah take him
down oh that G I wouldn't put that on
the podcast yeah they know they all know
yeah I still wouldn't do that
Oh cuz you don't know you don't need
Booker's looking at that this guy's
always a [ __ ] wild card yeah it was
uh
man it was a bummer it was some of it
was a bummer but some of we just moved
the dates and I'll just feel better when
I get there but I was but I was just
like experienced like a ton of stress
man burnt out you know I've been on the
same tour for this hour for almost over
a year now
dude bands tour for like four years and
then [ __ ] go right back in the studio
make another one and keep going you got
a toughen up man yeah you're right huh
yeah what do I do have a slosh hat
looking like a [ __ ] backwoods guy all
tough and [ __ ] you can't handle doing
your hour again and may come on man suck
it up welcome and I think I need some
blood transfusions and I don't know what
he'll but it's not bad if there's the
other side to where you're getting run
down and you don't listen to it and then
you get sick so there's always that will
work yourself to death which I've seen a
few people doing this business literally
died yeah so there's definitely you know
why you're in touch with your feelings
that's that's good yeah man I got too
many of them I think if you beat me open
I'll just a lot of feelings sometimes
would come out too many you know I think
I'm less somehow I got caught up in some
of that feeling generation you know oh
just too many feelings what year were
you born ninety uh eighty eighty
nineteen eighty
nineteen eighty so oh yeah you're the
first millennial the first year of
millenials was like nineteen eighty or
something like that I could see that
yeah I thought they were all like you'd
be born like 2,000 or later but I meant
like you a bi and [ __ ] I think that's
all I care about
you know when well when do you finally
have money that you can buy [ __ ] and
it's usually around eighteen I think so
you would have been 90 maybe it's 82 I
don't [ __ ]
I think it's late yeah 80 I think was
still a little bit of like there was
still more like some you know heavy car
doors I remember a lot of that you know
the car was ever squeak and real heavy
you had to get your brother to help you
close it you know I remember more
station wagons big violent [ __ ]
station wagons Oh wagons are awesome I
love I love a station wagon I remember
the motor opening the car and just
seeing two pieces under there you know
that thing with the UM will you put the
air filter in and my mom would open that
and go like this and then close it back
up man your filter yeah air filter
housing I guess you care about your
carburetor come on I'm gonna open that
up and close it and then just [ __ ]
curse my dad that was it every time oh I
think she was probably [ __ ] with the
carburetor yeah I think she was trying
too long got an old cop car for a while
and that was pretty cool and we would
drive around at night and pretend to be
cops and [ __ ] it would be like a fun
thing we would do when we were kids and
it had one of those lights on the side
you know it had like that little hand
light out of the window oh yeah yeah
this is you're supposed to take some of
that [ __ ] I know you know little Matt
Dodge diplomat you got to take the
badges off of some of the [ __ ] I know
you can't have like police on the side
and then I also don't think you can have
the blue lights and in my state I think
you couldn't you couldn't have those big
searchlights either because they were
afraid you were gonna turn him on and
blind other people as they were driving
down the street there's new but people
would just be [ __ ] yeah if they did
I had a buddy my bought an old uh
Massachusetts State Trooper bike and it
still had the blue lights on it it was
funny he just thought it was the lenses
so he changed out the lenses and he
didn't realize that the bulbs were also
blue so we're gonna take it apart I
think he actually left him on for a
motorcycle yeah yeah I never had a
motorcycle man would we have we had some
four-wheelers we had things that we just
kind of people put together we had a guy
when I lived in Tucson they had a guy
had a school bus he cut the top off of
it and would drive it around a full like
convertible was it the full-size one
oh yeah now did it have an option
especially in Arizona we could maybe you
know here we see the Jeeps they have
like those tarp things you can put on
the top so the doors are off and all
that so you get the wind in your face
but you don't roast I would think you'd
want that in Arizona sometimes he would
put like a tarp over it at night and
stuff I think during like maybe I guess
the spring or something but I think
otherwise it was just just one option
open you know it is crew at any point
can I promote that I have a special out
here yeah that's streaming now on
Netflix called paper tiger tiger that's
right it was beautiful was it awesome to
shoot at the what's the name of the
place others Royal Albert Hall yeah I
loved how it was amazing
yeah because if you know even if I
didn't know you know some of the people
that have played that the second you
walked in there you would know that some
heavy hitters had been there so it was
pretty intimidating the first time I did
one show a year like about nine months
before I did that one that's was like
yeah let's shoot one here and then I the
first show that I did that was really in
my head a lot where I was just like so
you went to kind of not not run the hour
you want to just get a feel for the
venue first kind I just wanted to do he
was doing it and then when I did it then
the idea came about maybe do a special
here and then I talked to Mike binder
about it ya know binder yeah yeah and he
you know we smoked cigars so he's just
like he kind of did it I think as he
wanted to smoke a cigar with me in
London but just as funny as that is and
that's how we ended up going over there
but I've since watched all these videos
that I I'm kind of glad I didn't know
all these extra I just knew Zeppelin was
there that was my big thing that people
had the Beatles played there I even saw
I think George Michael they were doing a
thing for a while aids or saw no for
Lynne Linda McCartney yeah she lost her
arm right no she died yeah yeah she died
she lost it all oh yeah so they were
doing a thing and he came out and sang
like a Beale song and then sang one of
his songs are just like [ __ ] crushed
and I was just like I'm glad I didn't
watch that before because I made you
nervous yeah
it Lord yes sir then it makes you feel
like alright okay he's doing that and
Zeppelin's doing that and then I'm gonna
come in here with a bunch of dick and
[ __ ] jokes yeah and I took a tour the
place years and years and years ago and
I saw like the London Philharmonic was
there oh yeah
so playing all classical music so yeah I
definitely felt crass being there the
first time but then the second time the
pressure the special I gotta have a good
set you can kind of [ __ ] all that
history let me just go out make sure I
have a good time here so fortunately it
worked out and I think binder the way
you shot it put it over the top yeah
yeah some of the shots from the rear and
stuff but you can just see it looks like
you're performing like almost a just an
infinite amount of people at somebody
yeah it's not as big as you would think
but it's very it's it's big but it's
like really intimate it's like the sound
is perfect it's yeah man it's it's
something else I'll say that Susan my
oil again has been there remember her
who else no Paul I bet they've had it
seem like it has it plays been around
for a couple of hundred years since the
mid 1800s oh Jesus
yeah some guy it was probably the Prince
Albert now Prince Albert dude I love how
you just [ __ ] reach in for [ __ ] hits
a couple thousand years it's better
right Napoleon that's an old guy well
Prince Albert I believe it's Albert
Winston Churchill I'm sure he did
something there
he probably smoked a stick talk about
[ __ ] about the Germans yeah I know a lot
of people a lot of people played there
so historic that's what it looked like
yes yes so I had to make sure when we
shot it that we just didn't do that you
know the wham-bam way that they shoot so
many specials which I have avoided my
whole career because I've always tried
to work with people that really you know
wanted to make something great right not
just you know do the typical shots I
worked with Jake Harris oh my laughs my
plan is three you told me about him he's
great yeah yeah and he's like a Pryor
fan and that that shot that he thought
that single shot that you see that he
does in the my previous three specials
from the crowd is a nod to Richard Pryor
live on the Sunset Strip it's literally
a shot just for directors and if any
sort of like Pryor fanatics would know
would catch it yeah so I've always done
that because I have
liked specials were shot for a long long
time almost my whole career like they
would just you know and they look
similar they look bad they look there's
nothing that captures the who the comic
is at all a lot of times the audio on
the audience yeah he's so bad it's like
why even have it oh the worst is when
they put a whole bunch of him when they
would be doing a whole bunch of them
yeah and a group and they just would
crank out ten of them and then they
would be taking crowd shots from
somebody else's set it was just so gross
the whole thing was gross and just not
it was just all for cat for money the
whole thing which is oh these are cheap
to do get the comedian out there he's
already written you know if the penny
writers he's already written it he's the
performer Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
you know and then taking advantage of
you well I mean I I would it's they
apply a very efficient model that's
that's how that's how they look at it
yeah yeah thinking about how we think of
it no and you don't think I didn't think
of it at the first special I did I was I
didn't know I didn't know now it's like
okay I know I want directors that I know
care about me that want to make
something great and I want to have more
control over it and I know I can put an
audience in myself I don't have to spend
half the budget paying some lady to get
you know to guarantee a see I got all
the details on that I got burned a
couple times yeah like they somehow
figure out what your budget is yeah you
could have $8 or 80 million dollars in
their budgets gonna come in like two
cents below we can shoot this special
for $7.99 and then they find out you
have it you know not like you get eight
million but say you had eight mil a B
like yeah we did once what he wants it's
gonna be seven point nine nine nine nine
[ __ ] million dollars and it's just
like yeah the probably chips are out
it's weird it's gross though no way that
it was it
I stand up with such a weird thing where
it's totally respected and completely
disrespected it has this thing that
where it's just like when you meet
people aren't comedians so many people
say oh my god I can't believe you got
the balls to do that I would never do
that but whenever they show a comedian
it's always the worst like hey this guy
knows and I'm talking about like a
lampshade on the head and we're just
this loud obnoxious on offstage just oh
my
get this guy the [ __ ] away from me is
kind of how they do it which I know
because y'all so plain for laughs but I
don't know I don't know so I just you
know I've always tried to work with
people that love it and want to try and
make something great because you know if
you get somebody that knows what they're
doing they can they can actually help
the performance or it can go the other
way they can take something great and
make it not so good that's why I think
acting is so difficult cuz you just saw
with the mercy of so many things right
like you're not gonna edit it you can't
do the pacing what kind of music when
are they gonna cut out of this
especially like a comedy and [ __ ] it's
just like it's real scary I feel like
that's one reason is well I think acting
is real scary to me cuz I really kind of
I guess I kind of treasure the things
that I do do comedic ly and so I just
don't want to leave him at the at the
whims of some other you know some guy
who's been up for four just say you
treasure what you do like literally your
ass you're worried that's some big
Hollywood director ma you can't take
your comedic skills and say what the
[ __ ] somebody else wrote don't treasure
your acts so much know that what you're
trying to tell way that I present it man
the way that I present it if I give
somebody something if I do something
funny it's like yeah I'm gonna leave it
up to some [ __ ] that I feel like
doesn't know how to best this dude is
gonna be such a nightmare when he makes
it I'll I treasure these jokes how dare
you this this what do they call it this
is this is vulgar it is vulgar that is
Howard they tell ya but I think I have
like a thing yeah it's like I don't like
I have a tough time working I just think
I have a tough time working with other
people sometimes you know which is one
of the reasons why I got into comedy
anyway you know artistically I would say
get over that yeah get over yourself and
get over that because there's a lot of
great people in this business and you're
gonna miss out and I don't know know
what you'll say your loved ones will
save money on the funeral costs because
no one's gonna go so it's not gonna be
too many [ __ ] snacks they got to put
together yeah I guess yeah I don't know
I have a stuff just I have such a tough
time I think working with other people
man which is one of the reasons why I
just do stand-up you know it's like
that's the thing that I focus on mostly
and park
because you get to do it yourself you
know yeah I would get as at me so I
would try to get over whatever social
thing that that is yeah yeah dude if you
just by yourself all the time you're
slowly gonna go crow you start to go
crazy yeah yeah well everybody's got a
little bit of uh you know they got a
little bit of overgrowth on that root or
on that wallet you know and so sometimes
you got to tidy up the hair and your
nether region and that's why they have
something called manscaped and I got
manscaped and uh and I'm definitely
feeling a little bit more my pants go on
better my junk you know doesn't you know
it's like it's summertime so you can't
you got to make sure you really given
your you know your your Tahlia your
genetalia enough breathing room
manscaped is forever changing the
grooming game and they do it with that
perfect with that perfect package 2.0
and inside that perfect package you'll
find the electric trimmer called that
lawn mower 2.0 and this thing is in
gas-powered I don't ever bring anything
gas-powered around my Johnson you feel
me it's waterproof and skin safe
technology will protect you from nicking
your sack when you tidy up that bag it's
time to get clean with the perfect
package 2.0 from manscaped you can get
20% off and free shipping with the code
Theo th EO at manscaped comm and they
give you a whole kit to set up the balls
the wiping or everything you get that
hitter your balls will thank you get 20%
off and free shipping with that code
Theo at manscaped comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscape comm use
the code Theo and tidy up your regions
um
we had a question that came in about a
special didn't mean it about the special
now that you want to go to a video
question yeah let's do it yeah let's do
it
Gang Gang what's up deal
what's up player I got a question for
mr. Bert is this
we said another interview that he's
close to a year sober I was wondering if
you had any tips for recovering addicts
this question is coming all the way from
Newfoundland Canada I'm recently 38 days
clean dang header just added a facility
hook a brother up let me know hook a
brother up bill you a boy right there ah
well I'm not an addict
right I'm an idiot right so um I've
discovered with myself that if it's in
the house I'm gonna consume it right
I've said this in a number sugar liquor
whatever yeah if this if there's a
package of cookies I'm gonna eat it and
I'm not just gonna take two yeah and do
that moderate I'm gonna eat the whole
[ __ ] sleeve I do that with vanilla
creams yeah yeah M&Ms ice cream or booze
cigars so I can't have if I don't have
that [ __ ] in the house yeah I'm fine
because the cravings usually come at
night and then at night you just like I
drank it in the [ __ ] car to go down
and get whatever the hell I want so
that's how it works for me so this guy I
mean this guy just went to a facility 38
I mean that guy's like you know he's
that's like I'm playing touch football
this guy's in the pros so I'm not gonna
try to give him advice I am happy that
that's what he's doing but uh you feel
different after a year sober like do you
notice anything different if not
drinking for a year or like yeah my
cigar smoking went off the [ __ ] rails
yeah cuz then it just becomes like this
is what there's a thing that I'm trying
to work past right now that I've noticed
that through all of this [ __ ] that I've
done through just food booze and you
know cigars is every couple of days you
know or maybe even like once a day even
just like through food like I want some
sort of ramping up some sort of buzz
what an escalation yeah right and you
can do that through just going to
McDonald's people who are like obese and
[ __ ] like that that's their [ __ ]
thing yeah you can do anything I mean do
this in the I'll be honest with you this
is me relating to fat people there's
nothing better than giving into McDonald
oh my god it's the worst afterwards but
when you're in the [ __ ] drive-through
and you're pulling up like I am getting
every [ __ ] thing that I want here and
it's still gonna be under ten bucks and
it's just gonna grease Lisa sighs I mean
they give you that [ __ ] book and you
get the fresh French fries not the ones
that will lay in there I mean it's just
like and the Latinos make the best fries
too if you notice whoever's in the
window whenever you're driving by dude
if it's a Latino and their fries are
better 85 percent of the time really and
that's not my notice but I will say this
sometimes I talk to the person in the
window to make myself feel a little bit
better about the purchase do you ever do
that like to kind of take the edge off
of the fact that I know I have all shame
and the worst part is when I'm driving
home is the grease and salt mixture on
my steering wheel oh yeah from the front
it's like oh good yeah next day you wake
up with the distended belly no it kind
of doesn't at first and you think you
got away with it and then somewhere in
the afternoon it just creeps in oh I
don't have that yet yeah oh yeah oh you
don't well that's good that's good I've
had it something to look forward to but
no I think there's yeah there's
definitely some of there's like a thing
it like there's a certain thing in the
evening that happens to me where it's
like I need to do something
it could be booze it could be cigarettes
like when I could drink and I had
cigarettes I started smoke a cigarette
but it's always something pornography
dov chocolates dark chocolates yeah you
gotta find like you know what fascinates
me is like basically the first 16 or 17
years of my life when I never took a
couple sips might you know stole a beer
here for there for my dad but I never
really went out and tried to get drunk
it tells like 16 or 17 but I went for
like a decade and a half like I was
straightedge you know what I mean and
then but the thing was you told kid you
were straightedge you like I don't know
no good no just thought of being a kid
it's not like you first ten years of
your life is like [ __ ] playground man I
need a drink it's just not where your
world is that and the thing was it's
Pandora's box then once you catch a buzz
then it's just like oh man this is this
other kind of living and it's it's you
know I I yeah I didn't understand I was
kind of using that as like yeah I'm not
saying I'm never gonna [ __ ] drink
again but I didn't I had I had to like I
kind of just had to like step back and
just be like Oh cousin you know the
reality is I got a kid so I just didn't
want to be that I'm like you know it's
wrong clean your heads around my [ __ ]
Lou Grant with a bottle of whiskey and
the
remember that
Mary Tyler Moore Show she'd have a rough
day and she'd come in and I remember the
whole show I can explain it to you yeah
if I could explain it I don't know what
that is all right I don't know I don't
know and the second I started to explain
like I don't know the whole show all
right I get it I get it I believe that
comic a DD like I don't want even
[ __ ] I'm not into it I don't hear I
got it your show go ahead continue I
remember uh all right let's talk about
all chose then we don't have to I just
was so funny how you [ __ ] you bailed
twice on that you Mattie Duke what it
made me feel like an [ __ ] like that
was the fit every time I [ __ ] brought
it up sorry
no Mary Tyler Moore one of the great
ensemble [ __ ] cast of all time I do
know she does died recently yeah I mean
I was gonna bring up a more positive
story about the show but yeah it's the
second time I bring up the [ __ ]
George Michael was in an AIDS event huh
some sort of gay thing well I didn't say
gay bro why you say AIDS cuz he had AIDS
man no he didn't did he I Jesus now he's
dead well people have been saying he did
I think you are confusing it with gay no
I'm not I didn't know he was gay I knew
that apparently got AIDS in a park
that's what I heard and oh he blew a guy
in a porta potti and got busted for lewd
activity oh and then you know he you
know had a little [ __ ] you know he
liked getting a little buzz at the end
of the [ __ ] day and maybe it got away
from I think that's what happened but
like what I would like to focus on was
how amazing his voice was and I'll
talented he was and I played this
performed and stood in the same spot
that this guy did yeah that's what the
point was not what he died of
yeah oh wait a minute and I wished it
was what happened in your life who'd you
lose early on you're really into death
well no I mean I remember Liz I want to
get to know Mary Tyler Moore cuz you're
afraid she's gonna leave you too
I remember listening to Michael on the
school bus when I go to school and I
felt like and I would always sit by
myself like you were gonna catch aids
no doing that some sort of airborne HIV
through the [ __ ] radio I mean bro I
was holding it up to my ear and a
roofless school bus
wind-borne radio AIDS was going to get
me you think it's interesting that they
can like they can stop it but they can't
cure it and all those comics that have
done bits about how basically the the
money is in the treatment not in the
cure yeah and they kind of learned that
with polio because it seems like they
cured it but they're not gonna 100% cure
it because they want you to keep coming
back for the drug and get people on yeah
which you know probably [ __ ] with the
liver what seem like that with
everything I mean it's like how they how
some things are continued to be allowed
to like you know like even with our like
with automobiles like they can sure they
have something that would be you know
four years whether it would just be so
much less gas but they just give you
like one little piece every five years
source it's so [ __ ] stupid it's so
short-sighted all of that [ __ ] that has
happening is the number one [ __ ] thing
the number one thing as we're sitting
there focusing on like these stupid like
my new show words pronouns bathrooms
yeah it's like guys none of this is
gonna [ __ ] exist this is gonna be
like a Mad Max movie if you know you
know and just watching these politicians
that their hands a [ __ ] bound they
get paid such little money there so [ __ ]
job this so is and they're bought and
paid for it's great I think these should
have like I'm trying to have like
empathy for politicians as opposed to
just all the screaming and yelling and
then just oh you know anyway are the red
ties the one of fun or the blue tie
people they [ __ ] it all up you know
well you got you got it I think I think
there has to be something like I guess
individual citizens if yeah I think the
best way if you want to try to get
something going is try to start
something with your friends because if
you try to go through all of that [ __ ]
in DC like they always said if you
become president if you're lucky you get
one thing that you wanted to get done
you feel lucky you just get like that
one thing so I don't know it's too
depressing to watch I don't understand
news junkies oh why why you would
[ __ ] do that to yourself and the
[ __ ] stories that they show my god
it's just like I can't I want to [ __ ]
see this it's all sad stuff here's sad
stuff that you
can't do anything about and now you know
it yeah enjoy yourself try not to drink
tonight go to McDonald's yeah but do you
feel like there was a time though when
what makes you wonder it was her time
when the news was ever credible do you
feel like it was more credible when they
used to have law was it like rules of
sevens back in the day were like what no
no one person could own like seven a
combination of seven newspapers radio
stations and TV and like the same market
because the worry was like well that
they're all working for the same guy
than what he thinks is true is gonna be
what the people think is what they're
gonna think and then they just kept
deregulating and deregulating and
deregulating until now it's just
infinite so now you just have like two
towers of the their version of what's
going on here which is Fox News and CNN
and both of them are ridiculously biased
ya know it's Dick ulis I mean it's not
even anything anymore yeah well back in
the day like the like the way they did
it was the news guy you weren't supposed
like I got I got sports announcer you're
not supposed to hear them you can't
you're not supposed to know who is for
yeah of course every sports fans thinks
they can tell especially when that team
is losing these guys [ __ ] hates us so
they would just deliver the news as it
was and like he had a fax it seemed like
yeah and there was a lot more of
journalists breaking [ __ ] and and
bringing down like people who are really
doing some bad [ __ ] where now that's
kind of all gone away where everybody's
suck in the corporate [ __ ] so I think
that that's why now they're going after
like comedians and [ __ ] and I've always
joked that if we bought ad time on Fox
News and CNN all of this [ __ ] would go
away alone yeah well I mean at least at
least it would go away there I'm not
saying we'd go away on social media but
what were you surprised that you're
specially that did you get a lot of
notes on your special from people you
always gonna get sucker yeah but my I
was more surprised that people tried to
lump it in with the specials that they
did where I was just like I mean if you
look at it musically I mean a country
album is not a rock album
not a rap album so it's like it's all
like different am i special you know I
did some topical [ __ ] but most of what
it was about was me being and trying not
to be an angry [ __ ] and pass this on
to my kid and be a better husband and
just realizing how difficult I am to
live with that's what the main thing was
about but most people that ask me the
questions went for the same like hot
topic [ __ ] [ __ ] right like me to
stuff this yeah I'm trying to say that
which was you know that whole thing was
[ __ ] cuz Ellie would say you know it
was pretty harsh and blah blah blah it's
like oh what the part where I said it
happened to me and no one would give a
[ __ ] because I was a guy like they
didn't even [ __ ] you know didn't even
ask questions about that it was all just
like they just want to create it's just
all about creating more stuff not well
no it ya know it's it they're hacks and
what's funny is is if I told through the
[ __ ] that I think I just said this Don
Rogan like if I if I said the same ten
jokes you said you said the same ten
jokes every we looked at is the worst
[ __ ] comics out just hacks ok but if
you're a journalist for some reason they
can all ask the exact same five to ten
questions and you just want to be they
don't you have any pride in what you do
don't you want the person that you're
interviewing in to be like wow man I
know when you haven't ever asked me
that's a great for them to enjoy it as
opposed to rolling their eyes like [ __ ]
this again and just I had a guy started
an interview when he goes he goes don't
be alarmed by these questions I actually
liked your special and then it was just
one [ __ ] [ __ ] him I mean not yeah but
I know I've never take it to [ __ ] him it
was just like it was just disappointing
was just like oh god this again
we'll just no intake it's just like
there's no individuality it's um well I
think what it is is because there's so
much [ __ ] to look out there that you
have to go with controversy just to get
people to stop so they you get clicks on
your website and then there's like
advertising hits and the dangerous thing
about that is when that's where you're
steering the ship
you're gonna go at somebody who didn't
do anything right you know what I mean
and eventually you could get them caught
up under the [ __ ] farming equipment
which has happened to a number of
comedians yeah who got caught up in in
the [ __ ] wake of that Weinstein [ __ ]
and you know just to watch all of these
so-called social justice warriors to
sort of just collectively turn a blind
eye to that because they're so worried
about like losing this cold that they
have and it's just like but they're
losing the whole do you feel I mean that
hold I feel like is it's like I feel
like so many more people go out to see
comedians at have pockets just adjusting
to where it needed to go it probably had
to go past it had to go into like a
witch-hunt phase and it's gonna adjust
to now that if somebody does something
like that that someone can say something
and then it's fine it is far it's not
fine that the person did it but that
they'll be able to oh this is what this
is we know what this is let's
investigate this let's right I know
what's going on with la blah blah blah
they'll be like it's I feel like it's
it's going to a rational place where it
was totally irrational before agreed and
then it blew past rational and went all
the way around on the other side in this
Salem yeah which is how you know and
then it's yeah yeah yeah but that's
gonna end up in a comfortable spot yeah
I mean there's just no empathy it's a
lot of times what gives me is like
social justice like that like this whole
like judgement it's the same people that
will say like we need people to have
space to learn and space to be
themselves and figure out who they are
but then there's no empathy for anyone
when it comes to like a word or a
statement or something from a decade ago
or yeah when you go back in somebody's
past it's like you're not trying to find
out who they are you're going back to
find the mistake they made yeah and then
that mistake is who they are it's like
everything else that you did you could
literally be a [ __ ] Eagle Scout yeah
you know playing three shows at an old
folks home and helping out veterans and
all of this [ __ ] but one [ __ ] time
you did XY and Z that's who you are and
yeah you know I I would lie I just wish
that they would like you know if
somebody does that able going back 15
years I think we should go back 15 years
in this person's life it's like okay as
long as we're cool with doing it to you
to go and then we monitor yeah and then
we'll find them and there's no [ __ ]
way you can't go back in anybody's life
dude he can't go back 15 months in my
life and not find somebody that doesn't
[ __ ] like me or I said something that
I should
the [ __ ] said it's just like its
inherent off centimeter today that's
[ __ ] but everybody does this these
[ __ ] [ __ ] driving around like
they're these perfect people it's like
no you just don't have a podcast yeah
you know but this is the funny thing
here's all these [ __ ] people are
getting like this home security and all
this [ __ ] where you can see like the
[ __ ] thief and all that they're gonna
be recording themselves and they're
gonna be saying [ __ ] in their [ __ ]
houses and all these regular people
you're gonna find it just like anybody
else in the public eye like you you make
jokes you have the way that you joke
with your friends right it's normal
yeah it you can you know it's a joke
they don't know it's a joke but then
they hear your private conversation they
try to take outs like first of all this
is a private conversation
you shouldn't have been listening - yeah
there's no context that's the problem
with all of social media and everything
that's a problem even with like it's
like you can see something even on
Facebook or anywhere and you see
something you just see that clip that
bit you're like it gets a reaction but
you don't see the timeline you so you
don't have any context of where it plays
yeah and so then people constantly react
we got a kid laying in his bed right
here who sent this video and he had a
question that's related to all this all
right
what up Co loved the podcast what up
bill been a longtime fan I'm standing in
this video directly from a bed with an
open-ended question what do you guys
think of that comedian Shang Gilles that
was just like go from us now or really
just what do you think of the situation
in general thanks King game and you guys
commented on this on David Spade last
night was that last night yesterday yeah
no I just I think I just answered it I I
don't think it's fair I wouldn't want to
be judged by one thing that I did yeah
you know 10 15 years ago so that's
personally something I wouldn't do I
would never do that to someone right and
it's just I think it's it says a lot
about you as a person that you went out
and did that to him
is is I mean I don't think you know I
mean especially like as you starting out
as a comically oh you like your riffing
and stuff it's just like dude I got a
bit my act right now I that like the
first time I told it to women screamed
at me and walked out and [ __ ] then
you're late
wait wait waited to tell me me go [ __ ]
myself and all that and I got into him
went they you know and then I honed it
and I honed it and I only the other
night same [ __ ] joke this woman
oh my god I feel like you were talking
about my life and it's just like you
know so so what am I though which guy am
I am i that [ __ ] guy that made the
two women get [ __ ] mad and then I
told him to go [ __ ] themselves and then
they yelled at me you know I mean are
they better than I am you know I I just
don't I don't get how that works well
yeah I don't see how there's no
long-term value in it it just ends up
with a which on where we all cancel
everybody and I also think SNL was
getting [ __ ] for never having an Asian
cast member so then he said something
about Asians and then right they had to
look past their own [ __ ] there
[ __ ] it's like if he gets canceled
why doesn't SNL get canceled it took him
40 [ __ ] years yeah
to finally cast somebody Asian that's
okay but forever and this guy says one
[ __ ] Douglas yeah that's it and then
he's done and then that's who he is
forever yeah and this thing I don't know
the guy so I don't know who he is but
I'm not gonna just watch [ __ ] out a
second clip of somebody on a podcast be
like okay I know who that guy is and
whether or not he should do it and then
forget about the fact that like like
like the like how the punishment works
like I think how the punishment works as
far as being a stand-up comedian is if
you sell tickets and you're actually
gonna make some money you should never
do stand-up again yeah but if you're not
gonna sell tickets it's okay for you to
start a career as a comedian or continue
flailing as a community it doesn't even
make [ __ ] sense
yeah none of it none of it does but like
I said I think it's it's it's adjusting
back but it's gonna take some balls on
corporation sides to not give in to this
[ __ ] right and why cuz I can tell you
this because god forbid one [ __ ]
nickel rolls out the [ __ ] door for
our god for [ __ ] bid they don't give
a [ __ ] it's all about their brand and
keeping this [ __ ] thing going and
when I mean I get it to one level not
gonna let one person [ __ ] destroy a
forty-year March right I get that but I
just think that how quickly they just
cut and run but just to stand up and say
hey look we understand we're a company
that understands that people are people
and we all make
stakes and we all do things maybe out of
context from 15 years ago in our life
and we're an understanding company I
think yet because the way they support
that but the thing that they then let
this guy go because of that is now
you're validating that there's one bad
thing is who this person is right and
now he has to [ __ ] and carry that like
that's gonna be like his thing and it's
just like it's it's be so tough it's
horrific ly not fit it's not that's not
fair to the [ __ ] kid that did that to
him whoever started that it wouldn't be
fair to do it to that person because
there's no [ __ ] way right you can't
go back and do this to some and imagine
like what if that kids supposed to be as
Jango supposed to be one of the best
comedians ever what if he you know
that's his what is his destiny you know
where he's supposed to do something
novel and you also you also grow the
more you travel if you have your [ __ ]
eyes and your ears open oh yeah it's the
best thing about traveling because then
you have friends you have frames of
references and then [ __ ] that people say
and funny then you go back to your
hometown and the [ __ ] that people were
saying that was making sense now you
have can step back and be like that's
that's that's not right that's like cool
to say that oh I remember first time I
went to Africa man I was like holy [ __ ]
I had no idea that like other countries
I mean I knew they were real you know
from books and from like the globe
but I didn't know they were real from
till I went there and put my feet on
them I know but I know I know what you
mean well you know was great was was as
well is so [ __ ] mind-blowing is when
you go to Asia and you go there and cuz
they don't pay attention to it other
than this [ __ ] horseshit what we're
trying to start wars with people you go
there and it's like it's literally like
you went to another planet yeah you show
up and it's like they have their own pop
stars their own Airlines their their own
it's it's exactly like here completely
different and it's just like oh this is
their CBS this is there something and
it's just it was the [ __ ] coolest
thing and you know there's different
like cars like that they just don't put
out here in the US yeah like they'll
they'll have like like a couple like
Cujo is like a big thing like I kind of
saw when I was over there but like that
was sort of the the thrill of going over
there was watching like alright and they
could get like who's there Guns and
Roses like yeah these [ __ ] people go
crazy and like they're ac/dc knowledged
so I really got into the music when I
was over there
I couldn't understand what they were
saying but like but the energy but just
like laughs and watching it and then
you'd see but the way the person was
dressed and how the crowd was reacting
is it China yeah where was I think this
was a Singapore Hong Kong
Mumbai it just put the whole thing just
traveling through all right a Mamba is
beautiful yeah in Singapore Airlines
will they still have like the hot chick
[ __ ] stewardesses for some reason
that became like discontinued yeah like
this [ __ ] thing it's the greatest
thing ever oh and they all if used watch
them in the airport they'll move like a
school of fish almost yeah oh they're
all in a group and formation they're all
in like it's like a young beautiful
military day I know and you're just
sitting there like it makes you happy to
be on the airplane god forbid yeah god
forbid and then people just sit though I
kid she has to be beautiful of yes I
mean that candy that's [ __ ] part of
nature
yeah it's native people are trying to
act like that isn't a [ __ ] thing
anyway so nature is hating but here's
the thing before I [ __ ] trap before
you know did twenty-nine out and then
[ __ ] go there like [ __ ] to me that
was like factually acceptable joke
acceptable and all of that was was just
you know it adjusts yeah adjustment so
eyes how many people were like I grew up
in a small town we just had you know it
was like probably maybe 70% white 30%
black and it was pretty poor town and I
remember going to Africa's the first
country ever went to and I was like
whole continent it's not a country yeah
and I remember thinking holy [ __ ] dude
all these people are gonna be in heaven
that's what I never realized and I was
like [ __ ] cuz I always pictured heaven
like just the people from my town we're
gonna be there and then I remember going
to this place and being like holy [ __ ]
man what are we gonna do now in heaven
it's gonna be packed that was my first
thought do you believe in heaven yeah
and I thought well when we die dude it's
gonna be packed and so then suddenly I
had all this anxiety like you know like
um
get Sun anxiety but just like you know
like [ __ ] man I got a rethink you know
what you're after life yeah and so I was
like yeah reason it's a room for
Africans and you're yeah afterlife and
there's a lot of room form there you got
to see how many you're havin act or you
gotta see how many are coming but then I
went to end I went to India one time and
I saw like some kids they're smiling and
playing and dude to this day I've never
seen as much joy come out of like a
group of kids then for some reason just
like I had a great time in India they
were like friendliest people well they
were ball breakers I was really amazed
at the sense of humor that was over
there because that's not something you
hear about when we when we talk about
India we talk about the food we talk
about the religion caste system the
sacred cow this hacky [ __ ] the the the
style address but they never talked
about the people and I got there and
they were really really funny like just
ball breakers like the comics like broke
balls it was really really funny and it
was yeah that was a great time I was
just a little scary to go to as far as
like when I got like I had to get a work
permit to go there and then when I went
there I had to get them to sign a piece
of paper so it was okay for me to leave
and I didn't like that yeah at all like
almost like checking in for school or so
like you know I had to go to like this
[ __ ] embassy thing and they wouldn't
let the promoter come in there and I was
sitting there with some chick from
Afghanistan and we're both looking each
other like a they gonna let's let us out
of here
what of us and and there was like you
know when they do this thing what they
don't when you ask him a question they
don't nod yes or shake no like they kind
of do like oh yeah they did
they do this [ __ ] yeah yeah that was
like all right so I got this piece of
paper I'm doing my show tonight and then
I'm going to the airport and I'll be
able to get out if I if I show him this
and she was just like yeah doing this
it's like lady I'm on the other side of
the [ __ ] globe yeah what do you guys
own me now what what's going on here am
I in when they were in that [ __ ] with
that guy take the drugs to him what the
[ __ ] was that movie I don't know what
the [ __ ] women in on now this is before
you will you this is when you were real
young a Midnight Express oh you haven't
you guys when Tom Hanks just file that
under Mary Tyler Moore yeah oh that's
Polar Express
yeah Polar Express um anyway it was yet
that was the only part of the trip that
I didn't like and it was I found out
that it's harder for people who lived on
the west coast to get out of there than
on the East Coast which means some
senator said something or did something
and [ __ ] with them so this is their
political [ __ ] you back Wow
yeah because there was some I'm not good
with the name some beautiful pop star
American like when I was Norah Jones you
know
piano playing gorgeous women she went
there and she couldn't get out he's what
the promoter told me so I was thinking
like alright if they don't let somebody
who looks like that get out there's no
[ __ ] way I'm getting out yeah so what
was good was I had a red-eye flight and
I showed up in a handed the paper and
the guy was [ __ ] doing this [ __ ] and
I just gorillas my way through that
middleman yeah I was just like dude it's
the paper I have to go I gotta go
and he they just [ __ ] stamped it and
then I felt like when that stamp hits I
don't I like when I landed another
airport and get on a different [ __ ]
plane we were connected and Dubai and I
was just like as we won the the tarmac I
felt like I was in that Ben Affleck
movie that are yeah Argo yeah these
jeeps were gonna come along the side so
once we took off I was kind of okay and
then when we landed in Dubai and we
switched over to air Emirates which I
swear to God is one of the most insane
[ __ ] planes I've seen pictures on LA
obscene and I used my sky miles so we
were like sitting up top first class so
when I got in there and we went to go to
I went to go to the bathroom and I went
in the back to there was a [ __ ] bar
that you could stand up while the plane
was going was like a semicircle had
enough for like six people to stand
around so I came back I said to my wife
go Nia come on back here she goes for
what go come here I got to show you this
and she's like what a [ __ ] look at
the bathroom so we come walk in it yeah
and she saw the bar I said I'd like to
buy you a drink
so then we sat down on like this bench
that had like this giant seat I think I
can't know it must have been individuals
cuz what if you sat down with some
stranger wouldn't want to do that but I
remembered it was one big seat belt but
we just sat there on a bench and I was
just laughing acting like I didn't know
her and hitting on her and like a Ron
Ron Burgundy kind of way so we were just
racking up and it was just this [ __ ]
awesome flight that was such an amazing
trip because we started in LA went to
Australia did a whole run there went to
New Zealand then Singapore then Hong
Kong then Mumbai Wow
and your wife went with you the whole
time yeah before I had a kid and then we
connected in Dubai and then flew to New
York then I did some gigs there and then
I flew so I literally flew around the
world on that so that gets back to you
we're like you know Africa exists but
you don't know how it exists - you go
there oh yeah and that was the thing
where like flying it's just like yeah at
all it all exists or this is like you
know it Steven Spielberg they paid him
to come up with some sort of like
scenery [ __ ] and give you the sensation
that you were flying I don't know yeah I
don't think they can do all that I think
a lot of people you know a lot of people
get in all that the flat earth and this
and that but I don't think that that's
really I think there could be something
going on I don't think that that's it
that's too easy if as far as what as far
as them making people like getting
people to act and stuff in Africa and
getting people I don't think somebody's
like making you know I've had you're
talking about Flat Earth oh I don't
think somebody's blows I wish you would
literally have to have the world
scientists in every single country yeah
get join on the same why they can't but
if they were able to do that then all
these wars are alive it yeah they can't
do that you know no by the way how much
longer are they gonna keep saying like
Iran Iran did something they're just
forcing us into that like well how the
[ __ ] are we gonna pay for every other
day there's an article I don't know I
think they want stupid I fell down in
Saudi Arabia we think Iran did it you
know what that's remaining member that
great Bill Hicks bit where he was like
you need to pick up the gun uh-uh
Oh God you got to hear that one it's a
Jay's a reference to a Jack Palance
movie which you don't know and you
probably don't give a [ __ ] but I
remember Barbie uh no Barnaby Collins
mmmm Barnaby Jones yeah Barnaby Jones no
that's the one I didn't watch [ __ ] oh it
was good man Bravo DSS Maddox y5o the
original buddy Ebsen remember him buddy
Ebsen no I think he was played Barnaby
Jones real hit her who is this right
here
Oh art Antonio Brown I would love to get
bills
Antonio Brown this isn't farting in the
face of the doctor this is unbelievable
I know God for to fast - I heard it was
in his face though I feel like that was
a little overblown but that was just one
one more in this series of incidences
what are your thoughts on him joining
the Patriots you go he's a great player
Paul virzi had the best take on that I
thought where he was wondering if some
of the concussions because he was a
really quiet guy you know the first half
of his career and then on a little
sudden out of nowhere there's all like
this erratic behavior there seems like a
big ego stuff yeah there's more of a
pump there's more of a circum there's a
lot of surrounding him like Kanye I I
don't I don't yeah I don't know what's
going on yeah I don't know what's going
on with that guy i but IV won't be
honest with you he was always on the
Steelers so I didn't really watch a lot
of his interviews but I just don't ever
remember him having much of a problem
while he was with Pittsburgh until the
end then all of a sudden it just became
like this this thing and then he goes to
Oakland has a problem with the helmet or
something like that I don't know I don't
know dude you know I gotta be honest
with you I really don't think any of
that's any of my business I don't know
why people post [ __ ] like that or he
wants to post it I don't give a [ __ ] I
just want to watch the game and right
this guy is a good guy and he's gonna be
great and he's gonna win with the
Patriots I hope we keep him and if he's
you know a knucklehead or did that [ __ ]
that they're suggesting he did then you
know you get rid of the guy it's as
simple as that but like I don't get into
the [ __ ] Real Housewife aspect of
sports I don't give a [ __ ] right about
right that's not who that it's not where
we're therefore as I mean well yeah I
want to watch the game I don't want to
sit in a [ __ ] tailgate [ __ ]
parking lot talking to some [ __ ]
about like somebody's what the [ __ ] did
you see what he did in the Dairy Queen
it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
viii isn't that for the local
authorities what are gonna be some
gumshoe here now what do you think about
the scandal
yeah it's like I'm a sports fan I don't
think I just [ __ ] watch this [ __ ] and
react to stuff that has nothing to do
with my life and I enjoy it
I'll tell you what you got to get into
you got to get into motorcycle racing
you got to get an a MotoGP really that
[ __ ] is the best [ __ ] racing out
there and these guys are out of their
[ __ ] minds in a great way do they do
it here in the US do they have one race
a year I'm going next year in Austin
they have one Formula One race here I'll
go in the same place I'm [ __ ] going
man it's like every race it's like gets
down to like the final lap and they pass
each other like three or four times and
they're on a track oh wow oh yeah oh
yeah my niece does dirt biking but oh
that was Andre divisio so number four in
Marc Marquez that was in what the [ __ ]
was that one that that last lap of that
[ __ ] race is insane Wow this is every
last lap from 2019 oh it is yeah it's
instant listen you don't get this in
Formula one because once Lewis Hamilton
gets in the front you can take the rap
you can take a [ __ ] nap it's over
yeah look at that [ __ ] the Ducati is
going trying to get past the hole on
this straightaway they go over 200 miles
an hour and I think they're doing like
70 or something in the turns
it's [ __ ] insane Wow let's balls yeah
do you have a lot of hobbies bill I get
into [ __ ] man you have a lot of things
you like you know I need to give her
these guys look at that guy or this dead
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's Italian right
there yeah you can't get that accantus
love and your [ __ ] arms if you're not
Italian bro yeah the one oh they all get
that look at those guys yeah they're
like it's like they were on a [ __ ]
horse and they're like banging into each
other see now he came on the brakes too
late there so you went too hot in the
corner the guy in the red so he ducked
down I don't know a lot about it but I
just watches it this [ __ ] has me come up
off my couch you are I wonder if they
have radio and their helmet you think oh
they're probably listening to the boss
huh no you see him pop there with that
really not a frustration yeah he got me
these sometimes wish that you had
another life to do something that was a
little bit more violent like that like
you think that's violent that's a little
I mean it's it I think the results well
if this is the family of Ireland or
whatever they what does it call when
you're like Oh more adrenaline rush yeah
yeah
no I think I got this life right as far
as like well I I feel like I'm doing
what I'm supposed to do but like I will
say though as far as racing goes I've
gotten into it where I've watched like
old Formula One and old MotoGP and I got
tell you the second you press play it's
immediately scary like these guys could
die and people died a lot like
ridiculously a lot back in the 50s and
60s and we was [ __ ] insane
I read this book called your listeners
are into racing I've read this book
called No Limit and which is basically
where these guys try to push the car
basically the or the bike or whatever
you're racing the absolute limit of the
performance before you [ __ ] crash
like that's where you have to be racing
or somebody else is gonna take it to the
limit right and you and you act like a
[ __ ] test pilot you got to figure out
where that is so this book is about the
first American who won the the Formula
One mm-hmm yeah I was a [ __ ] amazing
book so you and he was the first
American not only to win the
championship in Formula One but also to
drive for Ferrari and we were just
considered inferior Wow because we got
all this space out a formula 1 is just
takes place in Europe well I mean it's
was I think it believed it started over
them not quite sure over them but it
started over there Brazil has a mailman
well they have a race there ok but as
far as the cars it's it's mainly German
Italian British kind of car in there I
know I'll just throughout the years
whatever so this guy gets a job the
American mm-hmm gets a job driving for
Ferrari so he gets his race car in the
film in the book in the book yeah so
when he gets the car he notices in the
the the floorboards I guess which are
just all metal I think at that point
there was there was a hole in it and it
was basically the last guy who drove it
got decapitated and he bled out in the
car and how they hosed the water out
they just drilled a hole so he's gay
dude it's it's [ __ ] intense damn so
these guys dude they would die people in
the crowd would die they had won this
guy's [ __ ] had an accident right they
[ __ ] hit each other the hood came off
went into the crowd like a Chinese star
and decapitated like six people and this
guy landed on like in almost concur
barriers yeah and I'm just landed dead
in front of the car on the all on fire
oh yeah this video of it I forget I
forget where the crash was they don't
they don't show the decapitation but you
see this hood [ __ ] go into the crowd
to be more searched I would say Formula
One there was a German guy whose
nickname was crash or something like
that he wanted
I saw a vintage Formula One German crash
crowd death there you go that's how I
look for [ __ ] I gotta do this it's all a
[ __ ] Pirelli go into uh front of a it
was from popeyes chicken one time off a
highway 190 over there by uh sir Kenny
Rogers Roasters remember that all I mean
yeah dude do that I mean that if that
[ __ ] can hit you in the chest I mean
just all your your [ __ ] your insides
are liquefied wide open that's it that's
the ultimate liver shot was it in 1961
the same years yeah of something like
that I would think of you around there
these [ __ ] people were standing I was
on a straightaway so they thought they
would say they were just they were just
behind a rope right here you go
tragedian Monza let's this might this
might be it
this is a name Wolfgang Wolfgang that's
him yeah there we go beautiful name
there we go let's see if this is it
seems to be the same footage over and
over again am I crazy oh they they cut
it out he went into the crowd you got to
get okay so Wolfgang von trips fatal
crash yeah see those people looking down
there looking down at dead people oh
there was a fence as a couple dead right
there looking two dead right through
there not to that there's their hats no
head oh my God look at that
yeah and that was it you couldn't sue
anybody unbelievable who's talking about
death now bill and he died that's the
Mary Tyler Moore circuit I know then
there there there is the one I don't
know know the name of the crash but
there's one with the [ __ ] what comes
off and the guy lands right on top of
the things and he's just make the balls
the balls it took to just race in the
[ __ ] 90s just the sound of
the cars they just sound scarier gasps
he's right there I felt like in the back
of the day like if I looked around in my
dad's car enough I could find a little
bit of gasoline you know like it was
always within arm's reach or within like
noses smell I got an old Ford pickup
like the gas tank is right behind the
seat and when I get low on gas I hear it
sloshing around the ability of an f-150
f100 oh that's awesome man what year is
it
68 I drove it over here oh you did yeah
yeah dude that's awesome yeah yeah I got
on the column but I mean it's not
something that I would want to get into
an accident with that's why you know cuz
a fire well yeah and also like there was
no crumple zones back then it was just
the engine went into your chest it's not
like a [ __ ] you know modern-day car we
can just hit [ __ ] and bounce it means
people still die but I'm just saying
like those yeah like it you you take I'd
rather die I think yeah you're in a yeah
like I'm looking change well depends it
depends yeah maybe like if it's a nice
day I would if it's a [ __ ] if it's
boiling out I think appends on what my
injuries are gonna be alright here we go
let's get a lay the first person wearing
a shirt I believe all right hey Bill hey
Theo this is Marissa from Raleigh North
Carolina and so bill I heard you say on
I believe it was Joe Rogan's podcast
that you really liked the film Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood and you've seen it
several times and I know Theo said that
he walked out halfway through it so I
was just wondering maybe if you could
talk about why you loved it so much and
Theo
why you walked out halfway through it
anyway Gang Gang well this is where bill
and I don't talk anymore after this no
no I didn't like you didn't like it
I absolutely [ __ ] loved it I heard on
your podcast you said you loved it oh my
god
dude it's the best work Leo's any Brad
Pitt's quit first time you watch it I
was just like I want to be like Brad
Pitt's the guy want to be yeah and then
the second time I watched it I was like
oh my god I'm just like Leo's character
I have an emotional [ __ ] mess well I
don't know what part you walked out and
I walked out after they went to that
house for the first time after they met
the old guy and then you were in the
yard and then his car was had a flat
tire and at that point I was like I got
to get out of here I don't know what
these guys are doing you know I felt
like it was just kind of a waste of I
don't know it just
get into it and I didn't know what was
going on and it made me feel
uncomfortable I was like I gotta get out
of here because I started to feel like
everybody knows what's going on and I
don't know what's going on
you know I guess yeah that's that's for
you and the therapist buddy yeah that
house do you at the [ __ ] movies if
you think the whole the whole movie
theater gives a [ __ ] about whether you
making like audible noises that you did
huh whoa oh that's the only way they
would know [ __ ] man I don't know uh so
[ __ ] up Mandy yeah you do yeah you do
you do I really didn't I really did it
man I'm not gonna sit here and try to
talk you into that masterpiece it's one
of my might be my favorite thing after
you said that's unbelievable do you
remember that show remember that movie
um dream team probably one of the best
movies ever remember Michael Keaton I
love Michael Keaton what was the dream
team will you show the picture I've seen
everything everything from mr. mom
Annette but the thing he did about like
when he was trying to run the American
car making company oh that was a great
one I know you talking about hold that
tiger that one when he's has a car the
the light in the middle no that's Kevin
Costner was in that no that was Tucker
with that was good yeah how good was
that they should remake that there you
go right there
I never saw that one Oh probably on the
top 20 or 30 films ever I think it's in
color too
dream team it's about four guys that
they're a mental health facility and
they finally get tickets to a baseball
game I never saw that one I've seen most
of his films you ever see founder is
that about the dog that dies no that's
about MacDonnell's oh my god yeah you
saw that right you liked that one no
good there you go you didn't walk out
you didn't feel like see that I
understand I like this one so much
talking can't handle this was like that
was sift it was subtitles I could see
why you wouldn't [ __ ] enjoy that
wouldn't did it for me bro that found it
was so good I love something has I think
more of like a like glory number two
movie glory about the slave fight from
nineteen uh no from 1700
wasn't that a Denzel Matthew Broderick
Denzel wash
damon wayans yeah so I don't think feel
like slice-of-life cuz from whatever
that was once upon a time a Hollywood
not a ton of narrative arc just that's
not slice of life that's what people are
saying that's what people are saying
bill it is slice of life yeah they're
just living ok can we look up the
definition I didn't know what it you
look up slice of life again
it was the Manson murders with a happy
ending that was the backdrop yeah I
liked uh oh I just like how he took all
the fear out of the Manson Family he's
like there's a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
hippies who killed a bunch of their
creative talented people in the prime of
their lives and then the other people
who weren't in show business down the
street that he didn't very say seem to
cover I know we talked about this before
bill off just on the phone but do you
like I have a tough time with like
giving away like when I do a special and
that sort of thing like doing giving
away the audio all that kind of stuff I
kind of just I guess not like letting go
of my material but I mean you treasure
the audio right why would you but did
you ever feel like that I'm sure cuz
you're you always seem like the guy
who's like wants to do it his own way
you know you have all things coming you
always seem like the guy that wants to
oh I have that with a bunch of other
people so that's me working with other
people right yeah see I opened it up and
look what happened and I'm putting on
Jessica Kirsten specials coming on next
words in Edwards is Ian talk yeah yeah
you and talk is out right now we did one
with Paul virzi you know um so yeah I
bet that I do I work with a bunch of
people al Madrigal yeah Mike Bertolli no
yeah Mike's great by the way
yes he is yes he is anyways but we what
we asked me just did you have a tough
time like I guess I don't know sometimes
I just have a tough time with that I
just have a tough time with like just
feel like I'm getting taken advantage of
constantly I guess is what it is yeah at
some point you you it's basically you
know a fighter knows how to take a punch
I mean that's the best you can do cuz
it's coming it's coming there's always
gonna be like it's very rare you know
that you know somebody there's always
there's always the [ __ ] that you're
gonna have to wade through so what you
need to get you need to get a really
lawyer and you have to be willing to
walk those are two huge things and then
you just kind of go from there and you
got to go with your gut and sometimes
they get you sometimes they don't but it
is not a you know business is not a fun
experience yeah just put it that way it
is just like lying and stealing either
probably the two number-one commandments
broken every [ __ ] 90th of a second
it's so that's what is which is what's
so funny about this whole dialogue out
there this is what do they call it
that's going on out there about how you
know men move through the world right
you just basically the doors fly open
and stuff like now dude it is a it is a
it's a [ __ ] party try to get your face
down every [ __ ] thing you walk and
that the whole thing that like this like
that is a guide your immune oh it's
horrible to this this [ __ ] yeah dude
the amount of times I've almost just
quit this business the only reason why I
didn't was because I realized that like
it's like well I'm just gonna get into
another business and it's gonna be the
same way right you know the nature of
business the nature of business is that
this is just yeah yeah people are gonna
[ __ ] try to put your face down in
their desk and if you let them look I'll
tell you this if you do a little bit of
uh you know gambling if you like to get
out there at the late-night hours and
lay a little wager down something fancy
you know maybe they got a ah a
Weimaraner is gonna do a run it's
running uphill against a beagle you know
you want to lay a few uh shillings on it
where you can
maybe you got a shrimp and a seahorse
wanna rassle and you can do that in the
yard and make you a little money but the
end at the end of a hard week it's great
to sit down take some time off and watch
football a more popular competition do
the smart thing when you do it and go to
my bookie dot a G no one gives you more
ways to win than they do my bookie I
just accidentally accidentally later
wager last week I'd bet I wanted to bet
the New Orleans Saints and that they get
ten wins
Sedan Talib at they get under ten wins
next thing you know drew brees goes down
and and I got a shot so I got a shot
accidental but maybe you can do better
than I can
don't forget where your betting is just
as important as who you're betting on
you don't want to be betting on one of
these places they're not real and it's
just a lady at our house counting all
your money you know if you're the kind
of guy that likes to bet a little and
win a lot try a parlay if your picks
come through you multiply your winnings
that's how you do it
join now get my bookie and they'll
double your first deposit yep so if you
want to lay a certain amount then
they'll match it for you it's like a 401
K for gambling use promo code Theo to
activate the offer that's promo code th
EO visit my bookie dot AG today that's
right my bookie dot AG today and they
will double which you lay down that
bonus amount and you play you win use
code Theo this past weekend is brought
to you by you know skill share you got
to have an ability some people you know
they might have an ability to make a
snow cone or they do painting somebody
do flooring somebody do fluoride a
dentist but Skillshare they do online
learning it's a community with more than
25,000 classes in business design and
more you can find all types of ways to
make your curiosity your creativity and
your career feel vibrant you you can
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion or get that side
hustle or get those pro skills those
professional abilities Skillshare is
there to keep you learning join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for tpw listeners you can get two
months of the enigmatic skill share for
free that's right skill share is
offering our listeners two months of
unlimited access you want that
access to over 25,000 classes for
free2go comm / Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm / Theo von
to start your two months now
that's Skillshare comm / Theo von get a
skill and get out there I'll give you
one even this even [ __ ] over zone little
[ __ ] watch your writer on the road
don't don't have a bunch of [ __ ] on your
rider because they're gonna go out and
they're gonna buy all of it in the
biggest size and overcharge you and
you're not going to consume it and then
they're gonna take it home themselves
Jesus yeah which is why my ride is like
bottled waters in a salad with the
protein yeah you know I got blueberries
and a little bit of cut Turkey from the
odd though yeah that's what you want to
do but if you start having like lamb or
some liquor and all no I'm just talking
like you know I want these candies I
want this they're gonna buy the
Halloween fat and that right there will
be a way to [ __ ] skim 200 bucks from
you yeah just that that's just in that
[ __ ] level forget about all the other
[ __ ] you know you get in with promoters
and they double triple quadruple [ __ ]
dip its yeah did you ever have to you
can't because cuz it makes it hard for
me to do my work cuz I get it so [ __ ]
mad having to be my own business person
sometimes you know I'm saying like or
having to feel like I'm getting I don't
know it just can't you can't take it
yeah I the problem I have is that the
people who do it sleep at night
comfortably they're just like yeah you
know I meant that's how business is done
this is how we do business so I guess
how you do business you can't do
business unless you're just [ __ ]
somebody over and stealing from them
yeah how do you feel when you sit in
your [ __ ] hot tub I don't know I got
[ __ ] issues in other areas yeah did I
love that line from your special about
the lady in the hot tub you like your
[ __ ] sitting right there next to me
oh yeah the way white women have
divorced themselves from their own white
privilege well I swung fell off of my
house why Micucci beat over the other
side of the fence to be victims is
[ __ ] hilarious let's take a question
right here we got another one speaking
of a white guy right here with all this
[ __ ] privilege
sending this in
hey Bill feel this is Luke hey Theo is
just wondering if you've ever flown in a
helicopter bill would you take them up
love be kind of a fun little trip and
Bill I know you're working on your
instrument rating keep plugging at a man
I'm an instrument and commercially rated
fixed-wing pilot so I know what you're
going through just hit that far am
brother
take care I never been in helicopter
I've been in like oh I've been in a
Blackhawk one time actually and I was
doing a show in Vaz Basra or something
and I got a blow job on an unsecured
airfield from a female and uh in the
middle of the night in a Blackhawk
helicopter praise God brother well there
you go
so yes he's been in a helicopter so I
have been in one but only with a gun you
know only when people had guns you keep
a weapon on yours or no on what in your
uh I don't if you have the helicopter if
you rent a la cop I really have to
answer that
he knows god damn well have a weapon why
are you doing this you don't you never
got think it's uh I don't think it's
obtuse really to think you might have a
weapon in there with you think about it
yeah think about you think about it this
is small God did as I am piece yeah no
okay fine fine bill it's [ __ ]
ridiculous question ringing who's he up
there would you flood fly is a hobby
here's another question about Bill's
interests I thought looks like Mila hey
Theo hey Bill
hey Theo I'm really looking forward to
seeing you in a couple weeks the Rat
Pack is gonna see their Lord and Savior
in Bethlehem Pennsylvania praise the God
brother crazy guy I'm currently smoking
a Sir Robert Peel slobbering all over it
that name is pretty pretentious but
onward bill yeah question to you isn't
smoking these Nick sticks it's been my
experience that the group of people the
subculture there's less knuckleheads yes
is that your experience yes and what's
your favorite cigar and or brand gang
gang all right yeah that's what it is
the conversation the people you hang
with I've I don't think I've
there's got to be one or two I don't
think I've ever met a cigar smoker who
wasn't [ __ ] cool and chill Chris
Carter smokes him he's on that
television show uh yeah a lot of
athletes smoke them my favorite one
right now I love those long auras that
come in those torpedo-like tubes and I
was an emerald guy now I like the
Sapphire the Sapphire that is my that's
my go-to I love Allah or cigars they got
these little ones at home Zeppelin's
they come twenty-two a box looking like
a little mini you know can you smoke
them at night when do you smoke them in
the morning what's the earliest you'll
smoke do you have a little bit of a
culture for yourself uh
well I'm trying to lay off them so I
kind of like you know I what I try to do
is because I have so many friends that
smoke that I try to get a large group
together rather than smoke with all of
eight people individually I try to get
all of us together so I just smoke once
but oh it's I got a back porch I like to
go out too but there's like this [ __ ]
psycho level mosquito out here now that
if you go out there at night like even
if you got clothes on it like [ __ ]
ghosts right through your clothes go wow
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] and even though
what does your wife's welcome to
sometimes or no no no no she does my
wife's coolest [ __ ] she's alright with
it like she sees me all like wound up
she owes much of my smoke a cigar oh wow
yeah go do some stand-up I think you
need to go do some stand-up like she
kind of like manages my like I start
bouncing around the [ __ ] house like
do you need to go out tonight like
what's going on with you but probably
and that's what I have to do I get in
the car and I [ __ ] porn on some ac/dc
fantasize that I'm in the band yeah
singing this lyrics and then when Angus
starts playing then I'm Angus whoever's
doing the most interesting [ __ ] during
the song is how self-involved I am as
I'm fantasizing as I Drive down the road
and then I go down to the store and
whenever I do some stand-up and then I
come back and then I'm more chill but
yeah I try - trying to smoke like once
every two weeks that's good yeah but I'm
not doing that
define did you like take to it right
away cuz I know you see you like force
yourself no you know what happened I was
on a movie and I bought a box of cigars
for everybody because we were going on
on a boat the director was taking us out
to go on this little boat
I think we're in Boston and it was just
too many non-smokers there and to just
bust out ten and everybody smoking would
have been obnoxious so I kept saying to
the other actions we're gonna hang we're
gonna hang right the little of lung we
just it just didn't happen and then I
didn't want to throw him out and I had
him and I was like [ __ ] and I never
smoked in a cigar by myself and I made
the mistake as I went out to my back
porch by myself and smoked one and this
just ate that habit well you and you
smoke a cigar even if you haven't done
[ __ ] that day you feel like you
conquered a country there's just it's
cuz this it's something it's inherently
obnoxious but it's delicious and it's
relaxing and I was just like I just
instantly in that moment I was like I
get this this is [ __ ] amazing and it
took a little while after that birth to
hold but it's been pretty bad for the
last five years so just keep trying and
I can get addicted did you ever do plug
tobacco do you ever do anything like
that now I never smile I was that's the
thing I never smoked or never smoked
weed never did any of that [ __ ] chew and
tobacco nope
never did it I was that kid that when
they came to school if I could just
reach one kid I was the guy that got
reached and uh yeah that's so we're in
my late 30s I think I found was just
like am I never gonna know what it feels
like to be stoned so I took a hit so
occasionally I do that you and the wife
will roll up a little blonde or no
sometimes it's a special occasion
anniversary uh yank maybe yeah it made
not really though not really
certainly and that's certainly not a
blunt I mean we're pretty like we just
[ __ ] we hang out she's cool as [ __ ]
so we sat there less what's cool right
now she you know she watches Real
Housewives which usually drives me nuts
but this one woman on there who's so
funny and just trashes which season is
it I don't know what it is but she just
says she was a dinner and this woman was
just running her Yap chicas you know
what she was fine that she ORS the word
freaking she's you're a freaking contest
and they all gasp OH
just [ __ ] called her a [ __ ] I was like
I like this and she just she just
doesn't give a [ __ ] her she's a dumbass
she's not even hurt the some Bulls
should happen she goes I guarantee she
goes to the emergency room and the chick
went to the emergency room she can she
live and when she went I called it yeah
I called it she sound like my
friends that watch sports so the fact
that she's on there I think is it I
think it's going to increase their male
viewership because other than that it's
just it's just I can't I mean need to
just screaming and yelling at each other
and then they then they even worse then
they got to work it out yeah and they're
always crying in the and there's a rich
well they at least they try to look rich
but they're also like always trying to
like do something spiritual yeah yeah
they're always getting crystals or
something or trying to go to Sydney yeah
that we want and rich white chick
[ __ ] it's got a it's yeah I don't
know what they're doing and they have
just sold their closer a lot the makeups
a lot the boat so the whole thing is
just everything is just extra yeah so
there's always been the rich have always
really driven me nuts I felt like
because I feel like that's one thing
it's fun to grow up with you don't grow
up with money is having that that
arch-nemesis in just the rich general
you know like we saw that kid that can
turn into self-sabotage so be careful
about that don't feel guilty about it
and like there's a lot of cool people
but I did a private party one time for a
self-made billionaire him and his two
brothers all became billionaires in
three different areas and like I met the
guy and like I didn't do well at the
party either was I was doing I opened
with the Michelle Obama bit yeah and you
know it was like a real liberal crowd
and was not look it was not the best way
to go had choice yeah
and but he was sitting there in the
middle big smile looking around he
[ __ ] loved in it afterwards when I
met him I was just like hey but he was
both going like he goes now that was
great it was great I got sorry about the
you know Obama thing kind of started off
bad and he just goes cousin I think it
was cool I I mean I I like the stuff you
was saying if they think you were saying
a lot of stuff that he's be heard he
just was the coolest guy ever
and then I was asking him where he was
from and he it turned out you know I had
you know great great great great
you know grandfather that grew up in the
same area and [ __ ] just ended up being
really cool and so you do meet like a
lot it's like when people say the LA
it's just a bunch of phony plastic
people and then you come out here and
you there's a lot of really [ __ ]
there's a lot of really plastic phony
people but there's also the all these
really cool people so it just depends on
how you're gonna look at it yeah yeah
maybe my perspectives
times I think well one thing definitely
is I've made more money even just in the
past year I finally started making money
you know and it's definitely been like
yeah sometimes even in the beginning of
this movie I'm gonna start yelling at
himself in the mirror like Leo and the
part before you walked out was it really
a piece of [ __ ] yeah
oh he yells at himself in the mirror
it's one of my favorite seats maybe I
gotta watch it again yeah you yeah you
don't have to I don't want to force well
I'm not gonna watch it cuz you want me
to watch it but I'll watch it maybe
because maybe I did miss something you
know I just said a certain point I'm
just like my favorite part of it was
that Brad Pitt had a little bit of like
a hitch in his walk a little bit if you
noticed that and about Leo with the put
the speech impediment that only happened
off I love how you just dismissed that
yeah oh my god that's amazing that's
what's amazing about when somebody makes
something like people's reaction like oh
my god this is the greatest thing ever
something else hey [ __ ] walked out I
get nervous the whole movie theater was
listening to my inner thoughts they
cared they cared this much about me I
don't think they care I [ __ ] care in
my head I cared I listened when I put
the hat on that means I got to go
that's fine I want to show you my truck
all right we got a weekend bond on
something we can agree we missed the
mark on Mary Tyler Moore yeah you
brought up something Emily man have you
seen that movie I've seen Family Guy hmm
what about the nice guys oh you got to
see that okay
you got to see that well that's a funny
one oh what's a nice guys know I don't
know I think you're looking down you get
your girl out you got your jaw that's
very confrontation I'm feeling like
you're not liking my suggestions I just
like you you like Tamara eyes upon a
time in Hollywood this guy's dead too
dead to me just to let you know I can't
hear your inner thoughts oh don't get
all [ __ ] weird it out I just walk out
already I feel like you're in my head
man super quick I really do a lot of
people ask this question and Mike do G
on patreon asks are you gonna get a
another dog once your daughter's older
yes
and what a lot of people don't know is
my dog is still my dog I just someone
else watches her for me and that's the
very convoluted contract had to be drawn
up because I'm still liable if the thing
does something I think
I don't know but like I am still taking
care of that dog she's gonna be in town
soon I still miss her I love hanging out
with her but I'm not gonna lie when I
brought her around the house I had her
on the leash just because I was feeling
guilty that I got rid of her gave her to
somebody else when she saw my daughter
she was cool
and I but I didn't let her anywhere near
her but then we set her down on the bed
where she used to be and she could sort
of glance and I saw her ears go up and
get fixated normally I give it a tug
just to kind of make her look at
something else I don't see what she does
and she looked at my cute little baby
and just went oh my god that's why you
don't live here and I haven't had guilt
about it ever since
I still miss that dog tremendously but
as my trainer said this is one of these
dogs nature said no to people said yes
to because even with his crazy skill set
like it took him a year just to have the
dog get used to all the other dogs that
it was living with now and to become
friends with one of them sort of and he
still has to watch because the other
thing about my dog was like when she
decided that she was going for it she
usually didn't do that she would just
look make the decision and then just go
so there was no warning and my trainer
was going this is a top-level predator
Wow it's like all right I'm never a baby
I can't [ __ ] do this so like a shark
ah yeah dude it was it and she's like
you and the dog meet up or like been oh
yeah yeah yeah no she comes
you know once every like six weeks you
know the guy who has him comes into LA
nice guy boards yeah yeah but it's a
trainer trainer yeah so that's why I
feel safe with the arrangement so he
brings her in and then I take it for
walks we have a great time and all of
that stuff and you know she's getting
older she's definitely since we let her
go she's kind of slowed down a little
bit but she's defied the laws of at like
a thousand times like a dog like that
especially as a pit bull would be put
down and
you know somebody had it for a year just
let her go we got her we had her in 2009
to the end of 2016 so we had about eight
and a half years damn my line my math is
wrong I think they're 90 yeah eight and
a half years and then he's had it for
like the last basically all of my
daughter's life we gave her away like a
year before my daughter's was born so
did you daughter know about the dog no
no no no no and I yeah I mean baby I'll
tell her about her somebody a dog was
crazy yeah he came at Dodgers had dog
was like a bouncer yeah if you got
grandfathered in and you were cool and
then once you anything after that was
like know who the [ __ ] is this this
person needs to be terminated D so ever
you ever donated sperm or anything like
that when you were coming up as a
comedian nope and I don't have a gun in
my helicopter but I want to thank you
for having me bet and helping me promote
my special I just have to get home to
worry about kids getting up from the nap
and it's my watch I love it all I and I
love everything that you're doing I'm so
happy for you and all thanks man you're
always you know you're doing it just
expand don't be afraid to get into
business with people get a good lawyer
all right all right thanks Bill thank
you
[Music]
oh but when I reach that round I'll
share this piece of my mouth I can
defeat it in my thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]